einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu zdf heute.de finden drei tagen am
sonntag schaut die republik nach sachsen
anhalt denn dort sind landtagswahlen das
für sich genommen wäre schon interessant
genug aber besonders interessant werden
diese wahlen dadurch dass es die letzten
vor der bundestagswahl sind und deswegen
natürlich auch ein großer stimmungstest
wie ist die lage in sachsen anhalt und
wie rechts wird die bevölkerung dort
wählen denn das ist auch kein geheimnis
in den jüngsten umfragen liegt die fdp
noch hinter der cdu ist aber eindeutig
zumindest zweitstärkste kraft und bevor
wir gleich mit unseren beiden gästen
diskutieren wollen wir vorher nochmal
ein schnelles ganz aktuelles
meinungsbild zeigen dass wir geholt
haben von den straßen der
landeshauptstadt
ich persönlich würde der afg vielleicht
eine chance geben dass sie ja man kann
halt immer noch danach entscheiden so
waren jetzt ihre beschlüsse gut oder
nicht
eigentlich nicht also es kann so bleiben
wie es ist nur keine afd
darf ich das sagen und fernsehen ich
interessiere mich wenn ich am sonntag
kommt da so nimmst du dann alle
[Musik]
nachfragen wie zufrieden
es ist eine frage ja mehr oder weniger
gut also zufrieden nicht aber auch nicht
so dass ich sagen könnte es war alles
schlecht ich sag's ihnen offen und
ehrlich ich wähle die afd
und wissen sie warum die sind zwar doof
aber schon aus aus dem damit die anderen
mal aufwachen
die waren sonst nie auf soweit also
einige stimmen aus magdeburg und damit
wären wir schon bei der interessanten
frage braucht es eben diesen denkzettel
in form der afg wir wollen diesen und
andere aspekte heute abend vertiefen mit
dr benjamin höhne politikwissenschaftler
er kommt gebürtig aus sachsen anhalt und
leitet das von ihm mit aufgebaute
institut für parlamentarismus forschung
in berlin der herr zur echten guten
abend und zur linken uns zugeschaltet
aus magdeburg ist unser studio leiter
andreas weise der den wahlkampf in
sachsen-anhalt von beginn an verfolgt
und journalistisch begleitet hat auch
die andreas noch mal einen schönen guten
abend herr höhne fangen wir mit ihnen an
am sonntag wird gewählt
rechnen sie mit großen überraschungen
gehört die größte überraschung wird
wahrscheinlich sein dass die fdp gut
abschneidet und das ist insofern
erstaunlich weil ihr eigentlich das
mobilisierende thema gefehlt hat also
das migrations thema ist nicht so da ist
weiß die pandemie in den vergangenen
monaten das bestimmende thema da haben
vor allem die regierenden parteien im
bund wie im land davon profitiert und ja
dann kann man auch sagen dass die afg
doch einen deutlichen rechtskurs in der
vergangenheit hingelegt hat vor allem im
osten aber auch zunehmend im westen und
das in der summe dass sie dann auch
relativ starke ergebnisse bei den
demoskopischen befragung jetzt im
vorfeld kam das ist doch schon
überraschung auch vielleicht vor dem
hintergrund dass sich der reiz des neuen
den sie ja einmal hatte auch ein
stückweit abgeschliffen hat also eine
gewöhnung eingetreten ist was dafür
spricht dass es zu einer verfestigung
von populistischen einstellungen in
teilen der bevölkerung gekommen ist ja
einige interesse
alle punkte die wir noch vertiefen
werden andreas wie nimmst du die
stimmung in der bevölkerung war er
wechselwillig oder eher richtung weiter
so also wechselstimmung nehme ich hier
in sachsen anhalt in dem sinne nicht
wahr was ich aber schon wahrnehme ist
auch durchaus eine große unzufriedenheit
mit denen da oben und es ist immer so
ein schöner sammelbegriff mit dem man
zum teil die landesligen aber vor allen
dingen die berliner politiker meint und
da geht es zum teil um corona da geht es
zum teil auch darum dass man meint hier
nicht wahrgenommen zu werden
und da ist die afg oder die wahl der afg
zumindest für viele ein probates mittel
um zu sagen hallo wir sind da ihr müsst
euch um uns kümmern und auch so ein
bisschen ja zu zeigen das ist der
protest damit wirbt ja auch die afg die
afd
wirkt ja auch nicht mit großen inhalten
zumindest was habe ich da nicht viel
gesehen auf den plakaten die größten
plakate da steht einfach nur drauf
widerstand wählen und das ist dann eben
die afg und davon versucht sie zu
profitieren das scheint ganz gut zu
gelingen
wie gesagt in den umfragen liegt die afg
ungefähr bei dem niveau wo sie vor fünf
jahren bei der letzten landtagswahl
gelegenheit schon und das ist auch
deswegen erstaunlich weil sie eigentlich
keinen wirklich charismatischen kopf
auch hier in sachsen anhalt an ihrer
spitze hat den hatte sie vor fünf jahren
mit andre poggenburg der durchaus auch
es geschafft hat so als einer
volkstribun hier aufzutreten
das hat sie in diesem wahlkampf nicht
deswegen stimmig stabile hülle durchaus
bei es ist wirklich erstaunlich dass die
afg sich hier gerade in sachsen anhalt
auf so einem hohen niveau zu
stabilisieren scheint
wir nehmen ja auch gerne unsere
zuschauer innen und userinnen mit ins
boot ich lese vielleicht gerade schon
mal eine stimmung vor von edwin trillion
auf youtube eine schande dass leute afd
wählen müssen um konservative politik
bekommen zu können
die cdu ist zu weit nach links gerutscht
und das ist fakt schreibt noch ein paar
sätze mehr aber das schon mal seine
meinung wir werden immer wieder einzelne
kommentare auch natürlich von euch
vorlesen die er uns schicken könnt an
die bekannten adressen und über die
bekannten kanäle bevor wir weiter
sprechen wollen wir uns gerade noch mal
ein bisschen auf den aktuellen stand
bringen lassen fakten und hintergründe
zur wahl mein kollege jonas pospech post
eschborn hat sich darum gekümmert
am 6 juni welt sachsen anhalt einen
neuen landtag die wahl ist aber auch
über das bundesland hinaus wichtig sie
ist der letzte stimmungstest vor der
bundestagswahl im september
laut zdf politbarometer vom 28 mai ist
für 41 prozent der wähler in
sachsen-anhalt die bundespolitik auch
wichtiger als die landespolitik außerdem
blicken viele gespannt darauf wie stark
die afg hier abschneidet reiner haseloff
von der cdu will nach der wahl weiter
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
bleiben
er selbst ist in umfragen sehr beliebt
ganze 68 prozent der sachsen anhaltiner
wollen haseloff weiter als
regierungschef für seine partei ist der
vorsprung deutlich geringer zwar ist die
cdu stärkste kraft im land aber die afg
bleibt weiter auf einem starken platz
zwei für haseloff kommt eine
zusammenarbeit mit der
rechtspopulistischen parteien nicht in
frage als innenminister holger
stahlknecht im dezember eine cdu
minderheitsregierung vorgeschlagen hat
wurde ja von haseloff entlassen
denn die minderheitsregierung wäre auf
stimmen der afg angewiesen gewesen
haseloff wünscht sich eine fortsetzung
seiner kenia koalition aus cdu spd und
grünen
zumindest in den umfragen wäre jedoch
eine sogenannte deutschland koalition
mit der fdp stadt im grünen beliebter
gerade der cdu bundesvorsitzende armin
laschet könnte gute nachrichten aus
sachsen-anhalt gebrauchen
bei den wahlen in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz hatte die cdu zuletzt
historisch schlechte ergebnisse
eingefahren und besonders bei den cdu
verbänden im osten deutschlands ist
laschet nicht so beliebt viele dort
hatten sich markus söder als
kanzlerkandidaten gewünscht den hat man
nicht bekommen sondern armin laschet
frage an den studioleiter war die
personalie laschet ein thema vielleicht
sogar ein problem im wahlkampf für die
union für die cdu das war zumindest in
den letzten wochen nicht wahrnehmbar in
der cdu hier in sachsen anhalt hat man
dann gehört der wahlkampf in zeitgleich
zu dem termin an wo armin laschet zum
kanzlerkandidaten gekürt wurde
okay er ist jetzt kanzlerkandidat er war
nicht unbedingt unser kandidat aber
jetzt vereinen wir uns hinter ihm und
machen zusammen wahlkampf also man hat
dann im endeffekt nur noch wirklich sehr
sehr wenig und sehr vereinzelt kritik an
der kür von lasche ziehen kann
kandidaten gehört und armin laschet war
ja auch da letzte woche zwei tage weil
hier in sachsen anhalt in dessau in
halle und im teil des braunkohlereviers
der hier in sachsen anhalt ist und da
haben laschet und reiner haseloff sehr
auf harmonie mich nur gemacht die kamen
auch wirklich echt rüber man weiß auch
hier in sachsen anhalt bei der cdu das
ist einfach nichts bringt da jetzt noch
dagegen zu stänkern und die beiden
favoriten für die partie wie den
parteivorsitz und für den
kanzlerkandidaten nämlich friedrich merz
auf der einen und markus söder von der
csu auf der anderen die waren ja auch
hier auf ganz besonderen wunsch der
sachsen-anhaltischen cdu war friedrich
merz schon relativ zeitig dann da und
dann markus söder war vor gut zwei
wochen dann da und war in leuna und hat
dort mit reiner haseloff wasserstoff
produktionswerke besichtigt
sachsen-anhalt versucht mit wasserstoff
hier in der zukunftstechnologie für sich
zu entdecken und zu entwickeln
ja und das zeigte dass man versucht alle
hierher zu holen das war sowieso ein
wahlkampf der vor allem auf eine person
ausgerichtet war und immer noch ist das
ist nämlich der ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff der als überall zu sehen mit
dem wird überall geworben so nach dem
motto das ist der ministerpräsident den
kennen sie es wird auch ein altes motto
aus der adenauerzeit herausgekramt
nämlich keine experimente das war mal
ende der 50er anfang der 60er jahre
schon ein slogan der cdu und jetzt
versucht man über diese schiene reiner
haseloff ist die zug das zugpferd hier
der cdu in sachsen anhalt und mit dem
will man dann auch am ende als erster
durchs ziel gehen
herr höhne kurzer blick über die
landesgrenzen hinaus wir haben gesagt
das ist auch ein wichtiger stimmungstest
für die bundespolitik
inwieweit oder was steht er jetzt für
die parteien aber auch für die führenden
personen auf dem spiel
ja das ist die letzte landtagswahl bevor
die bundestagswahl im september
stattfinden wird insofern wird man das
sehr sehr genau sich anschauen
aber ich glaube dass die wirkung am ende
doch begrenzt bleibt weil wir auch bei
den jüngsten landtagswahlen gesehen
haben dass die wählerinnen und wähler
doch differenziert werden
das heißt das landespolitische themen
und personen eine starke rolle spielen
die haben bei allen jüngeren
landtagswahlen gesehen baden-württemberg
rheinland-pfalz sachsen thüringen dass
die regierungspartei jeweils mit einem
personalisierungs bonus in die wahl
gegangen ist und den ersten platz
ihnen konnte deshalb das wäre bei der
persönliche prognose dass das auch in
sachsen-anhalt eintritt teilweise als
gesagt der ministerpräsident haseloff
ist obwohl es vielleicht nicht
ausgesprochen der charismatiker ist aber
es populär in sachsen anhalt und von
daher ja ich habe interessant wird die
koalitions konstellation sein wird man
es noch mal schaffen dass man das so
wiederauflage der kenya der ungeliebten
kenia koalition kommt oder wird man doch
ein experiment wagen aber kein
experiment machen möchte das passt also
eigentlich gar nicht so gut zur cdu und
ihrer lage
also kann sein dass man experimentiert
zum beispiel mit der deutschland
koalition das heißt die große koalition
plus die fdp nicht mehr die grünen weil
wir ja jetzt schon sehen dass sozusagen
da doch erhebliche differenzen zwischen
cdu und grünen vorliegen und beide
eigentlich gar nicht miteinander so
wirklich miteinander regieren wollen ist
aber mussten weil es keine politische
alternative gab
cashman 22 fragt uns über youtube ich
hätte mal eine frage warum ist die afg
eigentlich ausgerechnet in sachsen
anhalt so stark und diese frage gebe ich
gerne noch mal weiter an den
politikwissenschaftler wir haben es
gesagt es gibt also ein großes
wählerpotenzial für die afg im osten
generell aber eben insbesondere auch in
sachsen anhalt wie ist die partei dort
zu charakterisieren und warum hat sie so
einen zulauf
ja ich weiß nicht ob dir das ergebnis
der afg in sachsen anhalt jetzt so stark
sich unterscheidet von den ergebnissen
auf den anderen östlichen bundesländern
erreicht hat man kann aber sicherlich
sagen dass die afg im osten stärker ist
als im westen und dass die afb im osten
auch einen dezidierten rechtskurs fährt
das heißt sie schließlich nicht
konsequent sehen wir mal von einzelnen
personal in die camps in brandenburg ab
sie schließlich nicht konsequent von
rechtsaußen vom rechtsextremismus ab und
ich glaube dass teile in der afg denken
dass das auch ihr erfolgsrezept im osten
ist nämlich die afg hat na klar die
wählerinnen und wähler im blick die aus
protest die partei wählen
aber sie hat auch genauso die
wählerinnen und wähler im blick die
rechtsextremistische einstellungen
teilen und sie möchte beide binden und
im westen denkt man da er das ist ein
einen abschluss eine klare abgrenzung
nach ganz rechts außen geben muss weil
man sonst bürgerliche schichten in dem
stück weit verlieren würde
isabel schreibt uns über youtube die afg
vertritt sehr wohl sagt positionen groß
geschrieben es gibt sehr wohl plakate
wie windkraftausbau in der altmark
stoppen um ein beispiel zu nennen
kommen wir mal auf den spitzenkandidaten
zu sprechen das ist oliver kirchner er
ist wie gesagt spitzenkandidat afd
gehört zu dem inzwischen offiziell
aufgelösten flügel um die ecke den
rechtsextremisten und so hat sich
kirchner im wahlkampf unter anderem
angehört und so bin ich und weil ich
sagt der kunde aktiv werden möchte ich
dass das gesetz eingehalten wird
ich will daher alle ich lade
asylbewerber ohne grund mit abschieden
aktien
[Applaus]
so wie vorher illegal marktzulassungen
eine vergewaltigung gereicht haben
andreas eine relativ typische kirchner
wahlkampfrede inwieweit verfängt dass
bei den leuten wie ist er überhaupt so
als person zu charakter er dreht so ein
bisschen auf solchen wahlkampfreden
das hat man jetzt eben gerade gehört
ansonsten wirkt er in den gesprächen
durchaus auch zurückgenommen also er ist
jetzt keiner der einem auch irgendwie
ständig irgendwas um die ohren haut er
hat seine position zum beispiel die
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes das
ist für ihn klar ganz klar eine
politische vereinnahmung des
inlandsgeheimdienstes er vergleicht die
dann auch gern mit der staatssicherheit
vergisst aber dann auch dabei zu
erwähnen dass der verfassungsschutz
durchaus demokratisch legitimiert ist
dass die staatssicherheit der ddr ganz
sicher nicht wahr es ist auch
interessant zu sehen dass hier gerade
bei der afg so manches da wird auch so
ein bisschen nostalgie ddr-nostalgie
spielt da schon auch durchaus eine
kleine rolle das wird so ein bisschen
mit 1 gemengt dazwischen und das scheint
zu etwas zu sein was bei den leuten
ankommt oliver kirchner ist ein
magdeburger der kommt hier aus der
sachsen anhalt aus magdeburg das ist
einer der die sprache der leute auch
durchaus spricht auch wenn er definitiv
aus meiner sicht kein besonders
charismatischer redner ist aber er ist
einer der wo die leute sagen können ja
das oder zumindest ein teil der leute
sagen können ja das ist einer der wie
wir es der wissen wie wir denkt und so
weiter und so fort und dadurch kommt ein
ich glaube aber dass oliver kirchner
letztendlich nicht die entscheidende
figur ist für die stärke der afd
hier in sachsen anhalt es ist er
wirklich wie was vorhin schon gesagt
haben es ist die der protest ja wie den
widerstand zu zeigen das ist glaube ich
das was viele leute hier in sachsen
anhalt afd wählen lässt nicht unbedingt
die personen oliver kirchner
ja aber über ihn müssen wir halt eben
auch sprechen und er war unter anderem
auch mitglied in rechtsextremen facebook
gruppen auch das gehört ja zur wahrheit
dazu das sollte man wissen
ansonsten die frage noch mal von ralf h
über community youtube warum wird die
afg von allen so negativ dargestellt
sollten sich die anderen parteien nicht
endlich fragen was sie in den letzten
jahren falsch gemacht haben vielleicht
noch mal die frage an herrn höhne
das kann man auch ein stück weit an die
afg zurückgeben also wenn man sieht wie
die afg mit den schon länger etablierten
parteien in den parlamenten umgeht dann
beschimpfte die als altparteien als
kartell parteien
sie unterstellt diesen parteien dass sie
abgehoben sind dass sie die interessen
der bevölkerung gar nicht mehr richtig
wahrnehmen weil das sie vor allem an
sich selbst denken und da muss man schon
sagen als politikwissenschaftler der
sich in allen parteien befindet das ist
ein märchen weil meiner erfahrung nach
bemühen sich doch alle abgeordneten
doch sehr redlich jeweils um ihre
wählerinnen und wähler und versuchen
eben interessen aus der bevölkerung in
die parlamente hinein zu bringen
also das ist eigentlich eine infame
unterstellung der afd und natürlich gibt
es eine auseinandersetzung zwischen den
schon länger etablierten parteien und
der afd
und dann kommt die fdp daher und sagt
von sich selbst dass sie die eigentliche
interessenvertreterin die ware
interessenvertreterin der bevölkerung
ist und spricht den anderen parteien
stück weit ihre daseinsberechtigung ab
und das ist auch das gefährliche am
rechtspopulismus weil ich finde unsere
demokratie ist eine plurale demokratie
oder muss es anders denkende geben da
muss es unterschiedliche parteien
unterschiedliche vorstellungen davon
geben in welche richtung sich eine
gesellschaft entwickeln soll
und das alles untergräbt eine
populistische partei beschreibt uns über
youtube auch ob man das nun gut findet
oder nicht man wird damit leben müssen
dass die afg eine etablierte partei ist
sie wird zwar hier und da mal aus einem
landtag rausfliegen aber nie wieder ganz
verschwinden so seine einschätzung
würden sie dem zustimmen vielleicht noch
mal an der stelle herr höhne
ja auf jeden fall das ist eine
erscheinung unserer zeit alle
repräsentativen demokratien kennen
populistische parteien das müssen sich
immer rechtspopulistische parteien seien
in südeuropa auch linkspopulistische
parteien
insofern hat das
auch viel mit dem entwicklungsstand
unserer doch sehr ausdifferenzierten
repräsentativen demokratie und einer
sich zunehmend aus differenzierenden
pluralisierten gesellschaft zu tun
nämlich ankommen populisten und können
auf vermeintlich komplexe und schwierige
fragestellung relativ einfache antworten
geben und ja sie vertreten sagt
positionen weil das auch von einer von
einer zuschauerin kam sie sind zum
beispiel dafür dass man wieder zurück
kerzen zum abbau von braunkohle
aber da man sich dann konkret anschaut
welche politik sie in den parlamenten
machen sind jedoch ist die politik doch
eher konfrontativ angelegt und eben
nicht auf den kompromiss und auf
sachorientierte lösungen mit anderen
parteien ab ja also bei der braunkohle
ist der ausstieg beschlossen 2038 aber
eben genau die afg hat eine andere
meinung vielleicht noch mal auch an
dieser stelle das thema corona das
schreibt nämlich kloß mit soß corona ist
ein mobilisieren das thema und da
profitiert die afg natürlich als
einziger position gegen diese corona
politik andreas hast du das vielleicht
auch an deinen begegnungen mit menschen
wahrgenommen dass corona da doch noch
eine große rolle spielt ja corona spielt
natürlich eine große rolle letztendlich
sind ja alle nicht nur in sachsen anhalt
nicht nur in deutschland sondern
weltweit von dieser pandemie betroffen
ich würde aber nicht unbedingt sagen
dass nur die afg von mehr von ihnen
sozusagen von der kritik vor allen
dingen an den crooner maßnahmen
profitiert wir haben hier in sachsen
anhalt zum beispiel auch eine fdp die
von anfang an in ihrem wahlkampf auch
sehr stark die korona maßnahmen
kritisiert hat gesagt hat jetzt müsse
immer schluss sein jetzt müsse sozusagen
das land wieder hochgefahren werden das
ist auch der slogan mit dem die fdp hier
um stimmen wirbt und wenn die letzten
umfragen sich bewahrheiten dann schafft
es die fdp wieder in den landtag hinein
in sachsen-anhalt sie waren jetzt zehn
jahre lang nicht im landtag vertreten
und könnten es mit acht vielleicht auch
9 prozent in den landtag schaffen
und das sind sicherlich zum teil auch
potenziellen cdu-wähler die aber dann
eben nicht der afg ihre stimme geben
würden und davon könnte wir die fdp
profitieren
ansonsten von den anderen parteien ist
es so dass linke grüne und spd sich da
sehr zurückgehalten haben natürlich gab
es auch innerhalb der cdu hier in
sachsen anhalt kritik teilweise an den
crooner maßnahmen man darf auch nicht
vergessen dass zum beispiel
ministerpräsident haseloff
seit wochen schon gegen die bundes-
notbremse gebessert hat und auch immer
wieder betont dass genau diese bundes
notbremse ihm hier in sachsen anhalt
stimmen kostet denn es gab schon ein
paar pilotprojekt in der gastronomie in
der hotellerie die liefen einigermaßen
gut dann kamen die bundes notbremse das
musste wieder zugemacht werden alles hat
natürlich nicht gerade für super
stimmung gesorgt und deswegen versucht
reiner haseloff jetzt sozusagen mit
diesem mich in berlin stellte da so ein
bisschen die hoheit zu gewinnen schaut
her die berliner machen vieles falsch
wir versuchen oder wir machen alles
richtig
wir fragen gerade nochmal bzw geben die
frage weiter von feldmarschall es über
youtube was könnte folgen wenn die afg
stärkste kraft wird bei der landtagswahl
in sachsen-anhalt fragt er sich und
fragen wir uns das ist diese frage ist
natürlich sehr sehr hypothetisch
letztendlich geht die afg selbst nicht
davon aus dass sie den nächsten
ministerpräsidenten stellen werden
und ich denke mal auch nicht selbst wenn
die cdu auf platz zwei durch ziel geht
hier dass sie mit einer partei die vom
landesamt für verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden ernsthaft in
koalitionsverhandlungen eintreten
aber es wird natürlich schon in der cdu
für ein mittelschweres beben sorgen und
dann wird man sehen wie die
christdemokraten sich hier in sachsen
anhalt aufstellen am ende wird es dann
wieder eine koalition geben die dann im
prinzip entweder wenn es für kenia dann
trotzdem reichen sollte wenn der abstand
nicht allzu groß ist oder dann diese
sogenannte deutschland koalition spd cdu
und fdp
das wird man sehen müssen aber es ist
wirklich sehr misslich darüber jetzt zu
spekulieren
es ist natürlich auch das hauptziel vor
allen dingen der cdu und vor allem von
reiner haseloff genau das zu verhindern
und das ist wirklich das ist das ist das
ziel das ist das große ziel dann nur
darum geht es letztendlich in diesem
wahlkampf diesen abstand zu halten und
zu verhindern dass die afg stärkste
partei werden kann
in der tat hypothetische frage kommen
wir weiter oder machen weiter mit
tatsachen ein thema in den vergangenen
tagen war eben auch die äußerungen des
ost-beauftragten der bundesregierung
marco wanderwitz und er ist von der cdu
und er sagte er hat große vorbehalte
sollte das nicht direkt gesagt aber
sinngemäß gegenüber der demokratischen
gesinnung von teilen der bevölkerung
deutschlands wir wollen uns das zitat
zumindest einen teil dieses zitats
gerade auch nochmal anhören
wir haben es mit menschen zu tun die
teilweise in einer form diktatur
sozialisiert sind dass sie auch nach 30
jahren nicht in der demokratie
angekommen sind
ja das ist schon relativ starker tobak
erhöhen
es gab viel kritik an dieser und eben
auch an weiteren äußerungen von herrn
wanderwitz vor allem dass sie zu
pauschal sei die kanzlerin sagte man
dürfe die menschen auch nicht einfach
aufgeben sondern müssten sich immer
weiter bemühen diese dann auch zu
überzeugen
wie haben sie die einlassung von
wanderwitz aufgenommen naja ich hab das
auch nicht sehr produktiv was er da
gemacht hat war das überaus deutschland
zu sprechen ist der voraussetzung dass
solch ein sehr komplex und ich kann aus
meiner eigenen vergangenheit sagen ich
bin in der ddr geboren wurden aber das
hat noch nicht dafür dazu geführt dass
sich keine positive einstellung
gegenüber der övp deutschland entwickeln
konnte sondern eher im gegenteil wenn
ich mit meinen studieren entsprechend
und sage ich den dass eine demokratie
keine selbstverständlichkeit ist dass es
feinde der demokratie in der derzeitigen
form gibt und man auch über einiges
dafür tun muss dass diese demokratie
erhalten bleibt also sozusagen einfach
nur auf die sozialisation zu verweisen
das greift zu kurz aber sehr wohl kann
man über deprivation gefühle in der
deutschen gesellschaft sprechen also
gefühle das herabgesetzt sein gegenüber
den westdeutschen und es gibt ja nach
wie vor viele punkte über die man
sprechen muss die ostdeutsche auch
offensiver artikulieren also wenn man an
westdeutschen ostdeutschen eliten
positionen denkt wenn man ein
vermögensverteilung denkt die sozusagen
doch mit deutliche schere zwischen ost
und west auf aufweist wenn man ein
unterschiedliches lohngefälle denkt also
der mindestlohn ist in vielen teilen aus
deutschland der standard lohn könnte
ganz ganz viele weitere beispiele nennen
also darüber muss man reden
und das ist auch wichtig für eine
debatte und ich glaube dass ich auch
viel getan würde aber gern noch ein
punkt zudem davor sagen weil wenn die
afg weiß wovon ich nicht ausgehe
aber wenn die acht stärkste partei
werden sollte dann ist sondern am
parlamentarischen regierungssystem nicht
so dass sie damit automatisch den
auftrag hat die neue regierung zu bilden
das muss man immer ganz deutlich sagen
sondern die neue regierung
im parlament gewählt das heißt im
parlament muss sich eine mehrheit bilden
und diese mehrheit gewählt dann den
ministerpräsidenten die
ministerpräsidentin
das ist ganz ganz entscheidender punkt
also demokratie wird nicht unsere
demokratie wird nicht schlechter wenn
die partei die die meisten stimmen
bekommen hat am ende nicht den
ministerpräsidenten stellt sie müsste ja
in der tat auch jemanden finden der mit
ihren zusammen korreliert
wir gucken uns vielleicht gerade noch
mal die zahlen an die aktuellen also vom
28 mai zdf-politbarometer sehr zu
empfehlen auf unserer seite hier zdf.de
so unter sehen wenn nämlich dass die cdu
also mit 29 prozent vorne liegt vor der
afg aber immerhin noch 23 prozent also
schon deutlich weiter die linke mit
starken verlusten auf 11 die spd etwa
bei zehn grüne neuen fdp 8 die können
beide ihr ergebnis der vorwahlen von
2016 fast verdoppeln laut dieser
prognose also da ist schon einiges im
gange
andreas vielleicht auch gerade noch mal
an dich die frage wie erlebst du das
gefälle beziehungsweise das was herr
höhne gerade angesprochen hat ist das
etwas mit dem du tagtäglich auch noch
konfrontiert ist dass viele unzufrieden
sind weil sie sich eben im vergleich zum
westen vielleicht auch gerade was die
punkte angeht die höhle angesprochen hat
verteilung von zb bundesinstitutionen in
den neuen bundesländern dass es da noch
nicht genug gibt und so also dass ich da
so eine ungerechtigkeit eine gefühlte
ungerechtigkeit breit macht also das ist
jetzt nichts was einem tagtäglich
irgendwie aller fünf minuten vor die
füße fällt definitiv nicht gerade hier
in magdeburg ist eine landeshauptstadt
hier gibt es auch sehr viele landes
institutionen natürlich also in halle
und magdeburg habe ich jetzt nicht das
gefühl wenn man mal ein bisschen weiter
ins land rausfährt wenn man darunter
richtung mansfelder land hettstedt in
dieser ecke fährt da merkt man schon
dass das eine ecke ist die wirklich der
ist wirklich nicht gut geht ja der ist
wirklich das war früher bergbau das war
früher industrie aber das ist ja auch
kein ostdeutsches alleinstellungsmerkmal
und auch keines von sachsen-anhalt wir
haben ähnliche regionen im ruhrgebiet
wir haben ähnliche regionen in der
südpfalz da muss man nur mal nach
pirmasens kaiserslautern dort in die
ecke gucken das sieht jetzt auch nicht
wirklich alles rosig aus also ich glaube
was hier es ist das ist ein gefühl was
ich jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
immer äußert nach außen das ist jetzt
irgendwie
diese serien keine armen abgerissenen
mit den klamotten leute durch die
strassen ganz im gegenteil und magdeburg
zum beispiel lange hat sich auch
wahnsinnig gut entwickelt in den letzten
jahren aber das ist dieses gefühl sich
nicht wirklich hundertprozentig
verstanden und repräsentiert zu fühlen
das ist ja etwas was man nicht immer auf
außen vor sich herträgt es ist etwas was
man in sich hat und das ist glaube ich
etwas was hier wirklich in vielen
stellen weit verbreitet ist und dass man
auch immer wieder merkt woher kommen die
leute ist das invest dass ein ossi auch
wenn man diese begriffe vielleicht
furchtbar immer noch findet nach 30
jahren das spielt schon auch noch eine
rolle
ja das würde ich schon sagen und man ist
da schon sehr skeptisch und man wünscht
sich hier auch an vielen stellen
deutlich mehr ostdeutsche in
führungspositionen sei es in der politik
in anderen bereichen wenn man sich zum
beispiel das aktuelle kabinett von von
reiner haseloff anguckt da sind nicht
viele ostdeutsche drin er selber ist aus
sachsen anhalt
der bildungsminister ist aus sachsen
anhalt und ich weiß nicht ob mit krise
gar nicht ganz zusammen aber das ist
nicht viel die mehrheit der minister hat
westdeutsche wurzeln aber gleichzeitig
kann man natürlich auch mal die frage
stellen was ist denn überhaupt noch
westdeutsch und ostdeutsch ja diese
frage werden wir auch irgendwann
diskutieren müssen ist jemand der seit
30 jahren hier in sachsen anhalt lebt
ist das eigentlich noch ist dass der
ewige messi ja das ist die frage die
irgendwann auch mal gestellt werden muss
also das ist das ist so eine ganz
komische gefühlige gemenge lage die auch
immer wieder gerne mal dann zur unzeit
auch mal wieder aus schlägt das ist
zumindest mein eindruck hier bartsch
lukas fragt uns geht man davon aus dass
die wähler die während der momentanen
krise also gemeint ist offenbar corona
er ins extreme tendieren wieder in die
mitte zurück kommen oder ist die
spaltung der gesellschaft schon zu weit
fortgeschritten
vielleicht die frage an den
politikwissenschaftler wie schätzen sie
das ein
kann ich ganz schwer beantworten die
frage weil wir einfach gar keine
erfahrungswerte mit der pandemie haben
und gar nicht wissen wie sie das
wahlverhalten bei einem fluss also auf
breiter front im osten
sicherlich hat es hat das andere
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen es gab
einen digitalen wahlkampf der geführt
werden musste und man sagt in
krisenzeiten sind es vor allem die
regierenden parteien die davon
profitieren aber
vielmehr darüber hinaus kann ich ihnen
leider nicht sagen
jetzt haben wir viel über die rechten
parteien gesprochen lady of conan
schreibt ich wünsche mir dass die linke
sich wiederum ihre ursprünglichen themen
kümmert dann klappt es auch wieder mit
den wählern wie ist das vielleicht zu
erklären noch mal auch an dieser stelle
gerne an sie beide die frage
die linke hat ihr ergebnis oder droht
ist zumindest stark einzubüßen oder zu
verschlechtern wie wie ist das
eigentlich zu begründen warum verfängt
der protest für den die afg steht für
den die linke vielleicht auch stehen
könnte nicht so bei den wählern
darf ich vielleicht zuerst weil der rat
wird hatte zuletzt also auch schwer zu
sagen wo ich würde sagen 33 punkte
spielen dabei eine rolle
zum einen die fdp versuchte der
linkspartei den status als regionale
trust vertretungs partei für ostdeutsche
belange und auch als protestpartei
streitig zu machen dass es ganz klar zu
sehen dieses vorhaben dann soll ich
sagen dass soziale als thema was der
kernkompetenz der linkspartei ist das
haben die regierenden parteien im bund
wie im land in den vergangenen 12 13 14
monaten doch relativ gut beackert in der
pandemie sind sehr viele gelder
freigesetzt worden soziale härten wurden
abgemildert und dann ist ja ein
megathema das des umwelt und
klimaschutzes und das ist vor allem
darum bei den bündnisgrünen beheimatet
obwohl die linke auch versucht da
irgendwie zugang zu diesem thema zu
finden aber kernkompetenz bei der
bündnisgrünen und im zusammenspiel
dieser drei faktoren erklärt sich für
mich so ein bisschen die defensive
position der linkspartei
ja ich kann da auch eine nur zustimmen
es ist so dass die linke ihren status es
ist für mich die haupt erklärung als
protestpartei des ostens an die afg
verloren hat und dass die diejenigen die
früher eben links gewählt die linke
gewählt haben um sozusagen denen da oben
den wessis oder denen in berlin mal zu
zeigen wo der hammer hängt
die davon wählen jetzt anscheinend dann
doch relativ viele afd
eine frage vielleicht noch an den
politikwissenschaftler zum schluss nach
den möglichen regierungskoalitionen das
ist ja auch ganz interessant gewesen
wenn man sich das mal so ein bisschen
anschaut in der vorbereitung da sind ja
einige flaggen man lernt ja also immer
wieder neue sozusagen
und dazu die da jetzt in rede stehen
also es geht verschiedene es gibt
verschiedene möglichkeiten kenia ist
momentan am ruder dann gibt es die
deutschland kombinationen jamaika und
simbabwe mit der beteiligung von vier
parteien eigentlich alle außer links und
afd
wie ist das für sie als
politikwissenschaftler geht einem das
herz auf so als parlamentarismus
forscher werden wir da neuland
kennenlernen wie wie erleben sie das
wäre ja schon relatives neuland
kennengelernt und sachsen anhalt ist
auch immer gut für experimente für
koalitions experimente auch durch ein
haseloff und auch vielleicht bei der
nächsten landesregierung in der tat es
wird unübersichtlich ein stück weit man
kann aber schon sagen es wird mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit keinen keinen kein
bündnis geben wenn irgendwo die afd
eine rolle spielt das erklärte ziel des
kenya fortzusetzen also die derzeitige
koalition aus cdu spd und grünen aber
alle drei parteien wollen eigentlich gar
nicht so richtig miteinander koalieren
deshalb wäre meine prognose die wenn die
fdp reinkommen usa wo es derzeit danach
aussieht und zusammen mit der spd und
der cdu auf eine mehrheit im parlament
kommt dann wäre das doch schon ganz
heißer kandidat weiter quasi die grünen
aus der regierung raus gehen würden
wahrscheinlich das auch wollen die ja
jetzt denkbar weit von der cdu entfernt
sind und die fdp spd und cdu dann
zusammen doch ein stück weit näher
beieinander wären sollte es nicht für
eine dreier koalition reichen dann gibt
es noch die vierte
koalitionskonstellationen nämlich diese
waffe koalition
da werden dann alle parteien der mitte
unter einschluss der grünen und der fdp
zusammen eine koalition bilden aber das
wird nicht einfach also das hat aber
gezeigt dass er da auch schwierige
koalition managen kann also zutrauen
würde ich sie aber vier parteien in
einer regierung bedeutet auch ganz ganz
große kompromisse andreas vielleicht
noch einen schlusswort von dir ja also
ich glaube es ist zumindest von der
sachsen anhaltischen cdu ist definitiv
glaube ich der wunsch sehr weit
verbreitet nicht mehr mit den grünen
koalieren zu müssen
deswegen würde ich auch sagen wenn es
die möglichkeit gibt die so genannte
deutschland koalition zu bilden könnte
es durchaus darauf genauso aber
koalitionsverhandlungen sind langwierig
schwierig und man weiß nie wie es am
ende ausgeht also von daher
wir werden sehen wie es am sonntag
ausgeht und was dann sich für
möglichkeiten ergeben und die
regierungsbildung die könnte wirklich
eine ganze weile dauern wenn man dann
irgendwann mal alle bis man alle
möglichkeiten mal aus getestet hat ja
also am sonntag sind wir natürlich
schlauer aber ich denke wir haben uns
jetzt schon mal ganz gut gerüstet wir
wissen was da ungefähr kommen könnte und
um welche themen es geht ganz lieben
dank für das gespräch an meine beiden
gäste an andreas weise und an dr
benjamin höhne
es war sehr interessant und danke auch
an euch und ich will den hinweis noch
schnell geben dass die aktuellen zahlen
des politbarometers nochmal auf den
neuesten stand gebracht werden heute
abend 21 uhr 45 im heute-journal oder
dann eben auch auf heute de vielen dank
fürs interesse vielen dank für das
mitmachen und die kommentare wir hoffen
dass hat euch ein bisschen was gebracht
an erkenntnisgewinn sonntag wie gesagt
wird in sachsen anhalt gewählt sind alle
sehr gespannt zu euch einen schönen
abend und bis demnächst